[Musique]
merci merci je vous en prie agès Buin
installez-vous merci beaucoup vous être
notre invité ce matin vous êtes ancienne
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
et vous publiez ce journal votre journal
de bord de la crise covid de l'épidémie
c'est écrit entre janvier et juin 2020
c'est aux éditions flamarion d'abord
pourquoi vous avez choisi de publier ce
livre maintenant 3 ans après l'épidémie
j'ai d'abord j'ai souhaité que le le
traumatisme qu'on a tous vécu évidemment
les Français avec la
pandémie moi aussi dans mon vécu
personnel un traumatisme d'être accusé
voilà de ne rien avoir préparé ou fait
j'ai attendu que ce traumatisme
s'éloigne pour avoir un un regard plus
analytique euh et essayer de faire un
décryptage de ce qui nous est arrivé
collectivement le mot traumatisme est
fort vous dites d'ailleurs dans votre
livre relire ce journal m'a été parfois
par endroit douloureux oui bien sûr
parce que ça a été excessivement violent
et je l'ai compris comme un phénomène je
dirais naturel c'està-dire que au moment
du
confinement les Français ne sont pas
prêts ça arrive
brutalement c'est quelque chose qui n'a
jamais été vécu nulle part en tous les
cas de mémoire d'homme et la peur est
dans il faut trouver quelqu'un de
responsable de coupable et je comprends
très vite en fait que je suis la
coupable expiatoire de ce vous avez le
sentiment d'avoir été un bou émissaire
dans cette crise covid dans la gestion
de cette j'ai pas du tout envie de de
d'apparaître comme une victime après je
je voilà je suis très solide j'ai écrit
ce livre avec du recul j'étais très
factuel dans ce livre j'ai essayé
vraiment juste àoser les faits pour en
faire une analyse et un rour tour
d'expérience pour le collectif pour
qu'on soit mieux préparé les prochaines
fois alors justement on va y venir le
récit il commence à à Noël 2019 vous
êtes en Corse et c'est là que vous avez
la première alerte alors ce n pas une
alerte en fait je je suis un fil Twitter
comme tous les ministres qui regardent
Twitter mais j'ai à la fois sur Twitter
des alertes politiques et médicales
parce que je suis médecin et je vois
effectivement un tweet qui relaie un un
blog en anglais j'ai le souvenir que ça
vient d'un pays d'Asie je ne sais pas si
c'est Taïwan ou Singapour ou Hong Kong
et une radio de thorax trpatologieque
qui dit il y a des cas de pneuopathie
inexpliqué à en Chine et ça moi ça me
fait penser tout de suite au SRAS qui a
été vraiment une épidémie à corona
virirus dans les années 2000 très graves
mais quand on est en Asie et je me dis
il faut que je suive ça parce que ce qui
vient de Chine l'hiver est-ce que c'est
une grippe une grippe aviaèire une
grippe mutante un SRCE voilà je suis
médecin et donc je le ressens comme un
danger et on commence à suivre ça avec
le directeur général de la Santé dou
mais très vite ça raésonne en vous tout
de suite ça raésonne en moi pourquoi
aussi parce que quand on est médecin et
qu'on a fait de la santé publique on
sait qu'il y aura un jour une grande
pandémie donc quelque part j'ai l'esprit
préparé et je me dit j'espère que ce
n'est pas the big one vous savez comme
celui qu'on attend et et qu'on craint et
j'ai ce pressentiment à ce moment là
alors on s'est beaucoup interrogé sur
l'origine de ce virus et alors vous très
vite vous vous interroger avec Jérôme
Salomon sur le P4 c'est ces laboratoires
de recherche de haute sécurité et
d'ailleurs dans votre premier message à
éedouard Philippe on est le 11 janvier
vous dites on suspecte le labo pk de Wan
où a été découvert le le virus de
manipuler le virus pour vous c'est quoi
l'origine de ce virus parce que on a
l'impression que vous vous dites
finalement c'est un virus qui a été créé
alors c'est c'est la question que je me
pose au tout début en fait Jérôme
Salomon le directeur général de la Santé
m'alerte sur le fait que la ville où s
vit l'épidémie et la ville où se situe
le P4 et ce laboratoire de haute
sécurité je sais que la France est
impliquée dans le projet depuis les
années 2000 c'était un projet porté par
Jacques Chirac à l'époque et donc je me
dis mais j'espère que ça ne vient pas de
là et j'espère que la France n'est pas
impliquée en fait j'alerte le président
de la République sur un potentiel risque
en réalité depuis on a appris grâce au
service secret américain mais aussi
grâce aux missions de l'OMS que les
coronavirus à Wan étaient cultivés non
pas dans le P4 issu la collaboration
avec la France mais dans des P3 c'est
des laboratoires un peu moins de haute
sécurité parce que ça ne sont pas
considérés à priori comme des virus
hautement mortels comme Ébola ou la
variole donc en réalité aujourd'hui la
question qui se pose c'est est-ce que
c'est un virus d'origine animale où
est-ce que c'est issu de travaux de
laboratoire dans le P3 et donc pas dans
le P4 mais ça c'est quelque chose que
j'ai appris bien plus tard bien sûr vous
alertez rapidement he on disait on est
le 11 janvier Emmanuel Macron et Édouard
Philippe mais en même temps au début et
vous le dites he dans le livre il y
avait pas vraiment d'inquiétude sur la
transmissibilité de ce virus à l'homme
est-ce que ce qui explique est-ce que
c'est ce qui explique finalement que
l'inquiétude n'a pas été là au début du
côté de l'exécutif et des politiques je
pense que il y a eu une alors une
minimisation est-ce que c'est volontaire
ou pas de la transmission interhumaine
dans les alertes venant de Chine et donc
pendant longtemps jusqu'au 24 janvier
donc quasiment un mois après le début de
l'épidémie en Chine un mois où on nous
explique qu'il n'y a pas de transmission
interhumaine et si elle existe elle est
faible et donc et ça juste la Chine a pu
le cacher selon vous je ne sais pas
franchement je je je n'ai pas fait de
voilà je n'ai pas fait d'enquête
personnelle ce que je sais c'est que ça
ça a créé une fausse sécurité parce
qu'en réalité dès que vous comprenez
qu'il y a une transmission entre humains
vous comprenez que ça peut partir comme
un feu de forêt mais jusqu'au 24 janvier
on nous explique que ce sont uniquement
des gens qui ont été dans le marché aux
poissons à wouan et donc ça n'est pas du
tout le même risque évidemment moi je
comprends dans la semaine du 21 au 24
janvier parce qu'il y a déjà des rumeurs
qui courent qu'il y a potentiellement
une une transmission interhumaine et là
pour moi c'est pr le bas de combat et en
réalité je mets en tension tout le
ministère de la Santé nous commandons
des masques après nous commandons des
respirateurs nous alertons les hôpitaux
nous faisons trois réunions de criseire
donc en fait nous sommes très mobilisés
mais tout ça n'est pas vu par les
Français nous ne communiquons pas à et
dès la mi-janvier vous avez des points
réguliers sur le virus hein c'est ce que
vous dit absolument et et et enfin
pratiquement tous les jours on le voit
dans le dans le livre en réalité je suis
constamment obsédé par ce qui arrive
avec ce virus dans un agenda de ministre
extrêmement chargé par ailleurs mais
alors justement parce que vous racontez
aussi au début il y a pas que le covid
hein faut rappeler en ce moment-là à ce
moment-là vous êtes en pleine réforme
des retraites parce que vous aviez
évidemment d'autres dossiers à gérer
vous racontez plusieurs fois les thèmes
des questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement vous dites ministre de la
Santé on a énormément de questions il y
en avait pas une sur le covid et il y
avait les retraites il y avait
évidemment les inquiétudes autour de la
greffe des hôpitaux est-ce que c'est
aussi ça qui explique que le covid est
un petit peu passé au second plan au
début non je crois pas parce qu'en
réalité c'est un phénomène international
quand vous regardez les premières
alertes dans les journaux scientifiques
internationaux le le Land 7 vraiment le
premier moment où il considèr que ça va
être grave c'est en février et la
deuxème quinzaine de février donc il y a
une forme de dénis ça n'est pas vraiment
pas français c'est un déni international
on voit d'ailleurs que j'essaie
d'alerter tous mes collègues européens
que je n'y arrive pas que je mets 3
semaines à obtenir un conseil des
ministres européens en fait personne n'y
croit mais et il y a juste sur l'Europe
il y a aussi cette phrase vous racontez
un sms d'édard Philippe qui vous dis
certains jours je me demande à quoi sert
ce truc qui s'appelle
l'Europe oui parce qu'on est très énervé
on narrive pas à mobiliser la la
Communauté européenne ça n'intéresse pas
et elle a failli aussi
l'Europe j'ai envie de dire que
il faut lire le livre pour comprendre la
mécanique et les responsabilités de
chacun en réalité c'est une
responsabilité assez collective entre
les réseaux sociaux les médias les
scientifiques qui minimisent en
permanence en parlant de gripette en
fait il y a une forme de déni collectif
et c'est très difficile de mobiliser
dans un écosystème qui n'y croit pas
ouais et et qu'on comprend évidemment
très bien en lisant votre livre on va on
va avancer un peu on est le 21 janvier
là vous tenez un point presse et vous
dites le risque d'intr du virus est
faible sans pouvoir être exclu cont tenu
des liaisons aériennes avec la Chine et
cette déclaration elle va vous revenir
en boomerang oui c'est extraordinaire de
voir la manipulation en fait par les
réseaux sociaux en réalité il faut
comprendre que je suis la première au
monde à faire une conférence de presse
je fais une conférence je fais un point
presse quotidien au ministère à partir
du du 21 janvier pour faire monter le
niveau d'alerte dans l'esprit des gens
progressivement parce que je me dis que
ça risque d'être grave et qu'il faut que
les gens comprennent vers où on
s'achemine je commence ces conférences
de presse quotidienne 15 jours avant
l'OMS je suis la seule au monde à faire
ces points presse et c'est donc la
preuve que je suis inquiète et que je
veux communiquer c'est pas pour dire que
tout va bien et je vois le soir même sur
les bandeaux de télévision le risque est
faible et la phrase coupée et je me dis
mais c'est pas du tout ce que je veux
dire et le lendemain j'ai cré à mon
directeur de cabinet le le le le SMS est
dans le livre ça sort très mal c'est pas
du tout ce que je voulais dire il faut
qu'on rectifie le tire ça il y a une
sensation de banalisation c'est
exactement le contraire de ce que je
voulais faire donc on voit bien
l'enchaînement voilà catastrophique de
la mauvaise compréhension d'une mauvaise
communication j'en suis probablement
responsable mais en tous les cas
l'objectif c'était vraiment des phrases
tronqué oui les phrases tronquées on
connaît ça dans les médias le 24 janvier
vous posez la question des masques vous
posez la question de l'état des stocks
on vous rassure à commencé par Jérôme
Salomon hein vous le dites dans le livre
pas d'inquiétude sur les masques qui
vous dit et vous vous dites
instinctivement je sentais que le nombre
était insuffisant h oui enfin c'est
c'est je je peux même pas expliquer le
raisonnement parce que on on était en
train de marcher dans le couloir je
partais au Conseil des ministre avec mon
gros dossier de la réforme des retraites
que j'allais présenter en conseil des
ministres donc j'étais complètement
obnubilé par la la réforme à point le le
système universel des retraites enfin
c'était vraiment un très très gros
dossier du quinena et je sais pas en
passant je lu d comment dans encore des
masques mais ce ce que les
téléspectateurs doivent comprendre c'est
qu'à l'époque personne ne pouvait
imaginer qu'il faudrait porter des
masques en population général ça ça
n'avait jamais été proposé dans aucune
recommandation internationale et en fait
l'idée que toute la population devrait
porter un masque n'avait jamais été
anticipé donc les stocks n'ont jamais
été dimensionnés pour ça ils étaient
dimensionnés pour les éventuells malades
et pour les soignants et nous
recommandons énormément de masques
notamment pour les hôpitaux et et les
médecins libéraux mais est-ce qu'il y a
pas eu aussi des de la mauvaise
communication de la part du gouvernement
sur cette question des masques alors
notamment vous faites le Grand Jury on
est le 26 janvier vous le racontez pas
dans votre livre mais à ce grand jury
vous dites le masque bleu chirurgical ne
protège de rien est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
avec le recul vous vous dites que vous
aussi vous avez peut-être mal communiqué
sur cette question on peut dire que
c'est une mauvaise communication on peut
pas on peut pas refaire l'histoire
scientifique aucun aucune recommandation
dans aucune épidémie même stras même
merers n recommande des masques en
population général il faut regarder les
guides de l'OMS de 2018 c'est vraiment
fascinant ils disent que ça ne sert à
rien et que c'est même dangereux parce
qu'on les manipule et cetera on a un
virus qui arrive il est inconnu et
progressivement la communauté
scientifique comprend que les
caractéristiques du virus doit imposer
le port du mal mais ça c'est 2 mois
après cette phrase donc comment
voulez-vous que 2 mois avant alors que
le virus à l'époque où je parle où je
dis cela le virus est cantoné en Chine
nous ne connaissons pas les
caractéristiques de ce virus l'épidémie
n'a pas commencé ailleurs qu'en Chine et
donc voilà on ne peut pas refaire
l'histoire de la science la science elle
avance avec son rythme et les
recommandations ça fait partie des ratés
ça a susciter peut-être des
incompréhensions aussi chez les Français
on leur dit le masque est obligatoire
alors que de mois avant on leur disait
que ça servait à rien je vais vous
arrêter ça n'est pas une incompréhension
des Français il faut aussi arrêter de se
regarder le nombril en disant que le
gouvernement a mal communiqué
cette communication sur les masques elle
est internationale si vous regardez ce
qu'on fait les autres pays européens
alors je je veux pas parler de l'Asie
parce que les l'Asie ils ont des
pratiques du masque imp il y a quelque
chose de culturel regardez l'Europe
personne n'envisage le port du masque en
population générale en Europe personne
ne porte de masque avant le confinement
dans aucun pays d'Europe et donc en
réalité cette stratégie que l'on annonce
c'est pas une stratégie française c'est
la stratégie internationale recommandée
par l'OMS après l'OMS a rectifié le tir
très tard le 5 juin donc longtemps après
le début de l'épidémie vous voyez le
temps qu'il faut pour qu'une
connaissance scientifique imprègne
vraiment les décisions internationales
on va continuer à à dérouler ces mois on
est le 30 janvier vous alertez Édouard
Philippe sur la tenue des municipales
alors lui-même il est en pleine campagne
il allait se déclarer le lendemain à la
mairie du Havre pour vous on n'aurait
jamais dû maintenir ces élections
municipales écoutez c'est euh je je veux
pas refaire l'histoire là encore je je
livre ce livre factuellement avec mes
textau et je laisse je dirais les
lecteurs se faire leur propre opinion il
est clair que les deux dernières
semaines c'est-à-dire au moment où
l'épidémie flambe en France mais partout
dans le monde en fait hein c'est
vraiment le moment où ça part dans tous
les pays aux États-Unis en Europe il est
clair pour moi qu'on doit confiner et
c'est ce que j'exprime dans mes messages
au président de la République et au
Premier ministre et donc confiner
euh c'est compliqué de confiner de
maintenir des élections c'est pas tant
le maintien des élections qui m'a posé
problème parce que quelque part elles se
sont déroulées correctement les
gens gardai une certaine distance de
sécurité on se lavait les mains c'est
pas tant les élections en elles-mêm
c'est plutôt pourquoi avons-nous confiné
si tard alors que ça flambait je pense
qu'on aurait gagné en en
sérénité notamment pour nos hôpitaux et
nos réanimations si on avait pu confiner
une semaine avant comme voilà comme je
le demandais à l'époque et là-dessus
vous pintez la responsabilité aussi du
monde médical parce qu'il y a pas que le
monde politique il y a aussi le monde
médical et vous dites notamment on est
le 16 mars et alors le 16 mars on sent
qu'il y a un certain agacement un
certain énervement quand on quand on lit
ce chapitre plus qu'en colère on va y
venir mais vous dites ce soir la colère
m'envahit j'en veux à tous les médecins
scientifiques et experts qui ont pris la
parole partout pour banaliser depuis des
semaines j'en veux énormément au conseil
scientifique qui n'a pas recommandé le
confinement oui j'en veux parce que le
conseil scientifique se réunit commence
son travail une semaine avant le
confinement il publie deux avis un avis
du 12 mars un avis du 14 mars qui pour
moi je l'ai lis à ce moment-là me
paraisse absolument en dehors de la
plaque et donc je ne comprends pas et il
m'a fallu beaucoup de temps pour
comprendre comment ils en sont arrivés à
cette conclusion et je le décris dans le
livre et j'explique vraiment que c'est
un lié au fait à la composition du
conseil scientifique parce que il y a
dans le conseil scientifique
d'excellents scientifiques vraiment des
épidémiologistes les meilleurs
épidémiologistes français donc ça n'est
pas une question de qualité intrinsèque
des personnes c'est vraiment une
question d'organisation de composition
où on mélange la continuité de la vie de
la nation avec un temps de doublement de
4 jours des faits scientifiques qui
auraient dû obliger à confiner pour
éviter le débordement ou en tous les cas
le le l'afflux de malades dans les
hôpitaux à un moment donné et ils n'ont
pas été débordés puisque tout le monde a
été soigné mais il y a eu ce voilà un
sentiment que rien n'était maîtrisé
alors que si on avait confiné ne
serait-ce que 4 jours avant nous aurions
eu deux fois fois moins de malad ouais
c'est il y a quand même une
responsabilité de Jean-François d'elfri
vous n'êtes pas tendre avec lui alors je
je il y a pas d'avis personnel dans ce
livre en réalité ce livre est factuel
par les faits sont cruels donc c'est
vrai qu'on on voit des prises de parole
et on se rend compte qu'il ne prend pas
la mesure att temps je ne dis pas qu'il
l'a pas prise après qui ne prend pas la
mesure mais ce qui est plus intéressant
c'est que lui-même le dit dans un
interview sur France Inter en novembre
2020 il dit je n'ai qu'un regret nous
aurions dû confiner plus tôt personne ne
relève cette phrase pas une personne
depuis 4 ans ne relève cette phrase
quelles ont été les conclusions de la
crise c'est qu'il n'y avait avait pas
assez de l de réanimation ce n'est pas
ça le problème de la France c'est que
les personnes en charge de conseiller le
président de la République et l'exécutif
qui ne sont pas médecins n'ont pas pris
la mesure à temps de la gravité de
l'épidémie mais comment vous l'expliquez
ça je écoutez je crois qu'il faut lui
demander à lui pourquoi il a pris autant
de temps pour considérer que ça n'allait
pas être une gripette je je pense
que il vient du monde du sida c'est
peut-être quelque chose de voilà qui qui
va plus lentement et moi je pense que ça
n'est pas en fait lui personnellement je
pense que c'est le fait d'avoir mêlé
dans le conseil scientifique
l'acceptabilité sociétale des mesures et
un avis purement factuel scientifique
sur le temps de doublement et le risque
pour nos hôpitaux pour moi ça n'est
vraiment pas une question de personne
c'est une question de conception d'un
conseil scientifique qui ressemblait
plus à un conseil d'orientation citoyen
et qui a plus été écoutez de vous
écoutez vous parce que vous racontez
aussi dans ce livre votre sentiment de
ne pas avoir été entendu je suis une
candidate en campagne à ce moment-là je
suis candidate à la mairie de Paris
quelque part je ne suis plus pour pour
pour pour l'ensemble du du gouvernement
je ne suis plus médecin je ne suis plus
une ancienne ministre de la Santé je
suis une candidate femme politique à la
mairie de Paris et donc mes avis oui
n'ont pas l'air d'être entendu en tous
les cas ils sont uniquement parce que
vous êtes une candidate
c'est aussi parce que vous êtes une
femme parce que vous n'avez pas un poids
politique suffisant c'est c'est des
questions que je pose en livre c'est la
parole des femmes c'est le poids des
femmes en politique évidemment ça
interroge sur l'aspect genré de la crise
de la gestion de crise c'est quelque
chose qui m'a frappé j'ai remarqué
qu'aucune femme n'a jamais appelé le
coronavirus une gripette et donc ce
côté je vais savoir faire ne vous
inquiétez pas c'est une gripette ce côté
un peu viril euh bravache vis-à-vis de
l'épidémie c'est quelque chose que je
n'ai pas observé chez les femmes donc je
pense que ça doit nous faire réfléchir
collectivement à la parole des femmes à
la façon dont nous l'prenons vous
parliez évidemment de votre entrée en
campagne c'est aussi une partie
importante hein de ce livre puisque on
est en février 2020 vous vouliez pas y
aller vous le dites avant la vidéo de
Benjamin gveau vous faites une matinale
et vous dites c'est c'est ma décision je
veux pas y aller absolument et et
j'envoie d'ailleurs des textos dans la
semaine avant cette matinale de France
Inter j'envoie des textos au président
en disant j'ai pris ma décision je
n'irai même pas sur une liste je n'ai
pas le temps euh et effectivement
j'annonce sur France Inter que je n'irai
pas au municipal même pas tête de liste
même pas sur une liste j'abandonne j'ai
trop de travail et arrive l'affaire
gveau et je le découvre en sortant de
cette matinale et je comprends que tous
les regards vont se tourner vers moi et
voilà c'est un
sentiment qui était là encore
prémonitoire ouais mais pour pourquoi
vous y êtes allé c'est quoi c'est une
forme de loyauté vis-à-vis d'Emmanuel
Macron et d'Édouard Philippe c'est des
pressions que vous avez subi non je je
veux pas remettre la faute sur les
autres uniquement c'est vrai que j'ai
une pression énorme à la fin j'ai dit
oui donc à la fin c'est ma
responsabilité je pense que c'est un
concours de circonstances il y a eu
énormément de pression il y a ma loyauté
c'est vrai on me dit qu'on m'a donné la
chance d'être ministre qu'à un moment
faut rendre j'avais déjà refusé d'être
tête de liste aux Européennes donc deux
fois refusé au président de la
République
quand on est issu de la société civile
bon et puis il y a le fait que je
doutais moi-même c'est-à-dire qu'à
l'époque où ça survient il y a une forme
de faux plat dans l'épidémie il y a un
temps mort tout est cantonné en Chine il
y a pas encore d'épidémie en dehors de
Chine tout le monde considère que ça va
être une gripette on voit les les
émissions de télé de radio même un mois
après mon départ les scientifiques
disent encore que ça va être une
gripette donc vous imaginez le 15
février et donc et nous n'avons pas de
nouveau cas en France depuis une dizaine
de jours et je commence à douter de
moi-même je me dis mais si ça se trouve
je vois tout en noir peut-être que j'ai
paniqué alors c'est vrai que j'ai
vraiment mobilisé tout ce que je pouvais
mobiliser au ministère de la Santé et
tout le monde me regarde un peu comme
une folle et donc je commence à douter
bon voilà c'est un mélange de tout ça
qui fait qu'à un moment je dis oui euh
et je le regrette évidemment
immédiatement dès que je vois l'épidémie
démarré le 6 février en Italie là je
comprends que mon intuition était la
bonne que la gravité c'est bien ce que
ce que je suspectais et je comprends que
je n'aurais jamais dû partir ouais et et
vous le regrettez et je le disais on
sent votre colère au lendemain du
premier tour le soir du premier tour
c'est c'est d'ailleurs l'un des
chapitres les plus courts de votre livre
le soir du premier tour on a
l'impression que pour vous ça n'a pas
exist et et puis vous parlez d'élection
mascarade vous dites on a été assez
ridicule comme ça moi je veux pas faire
les tractations du second tour et vous
avez cette phrase que j'ai trouvé
marquante vous dites vous envoyez un SMS
à éedard Philippe moi aujourd'hui je
n'ai plus de boulot et lundi dit je
serai au front à l'hôpital et dans un
mois peut-être morte oui c'est c'est mon
sentiment à l'époque c'estàdire que il
est le le soir même du premier tour je
ne veux qu'une seule chose c'est
retourner travailler comme médecin à
l'hôpital pour participer à cette guerre
contre la maladie euh voilà donc
j'essaie de trouver un poste à l'hôpital
pour moi je me vis comme médecin
immédiatement face enfin c'est la c'est
la vocation d'un médecin d'être utile
donc je sais que je vais retourner
travailler et que je vais soigner des
gens atints de covid à l'époque on ne
sait absolument pas qui va vivre qui va
mourir la mortalité on découvre
l'épidémie elle arrive enfin enfin qu je
dirais malheureusement en Europe et donc
on va découvrir la réalité des chiffres
et c'est à cause de ce sentiment de
précarité en fait où je me dis que
peut-être que je vais mourir du
covid que j'écris pour mes enfants ce
journal je commence à écrire en lu
disant si je meurs je ne veux pas qu'ils
aient l'image de moi qu'on a donné dans
les médias et dans les réseaux sociaux
ils doivent connaître cette
histoire ouais et effectivement et à
partir du 22 mars vous écrivez tous les
jours avant vous êtes allé rechercher
dans vos agendas dans vos archives à
partir du du 22 mars vous écrivez tous
les jours alors vous le dites il y a
cette épidémie en Italie vous présentez
évidemment qu'elle va arriver en France
pourquoi Emmanuel Macron et Édouard
Philippe ont l'a aussi peut-être un peu
tardé à réagir mais regardez les
émissions de télé je retranscris les
émissions de télé de radio de cette
période là avec des gens réputés que
nous connaissons tous sur les plateaux
télé qui sont des médecins éminents des
présidents de syndicat enfin vraiment
des gens que tout le monde connaît
regardez les prises de parole pendant
cette période tout le monde minimise
comment voulez-vous que des politiques
qui ne sont pas médecins qui sont
obligés d'entendre les conseils de
scientifiques puissent prendre la mesure
de quelque chose qui est min misé par la
majorité moi je suis certaine qu'il y a
des médecins qui comme moi était
terrorisé j'en suis certaine mais
malheureusement ils n'ont pas été
invités sur les plateaux télé ou alors
ils n'ont pas voulu s'exprimer est-ce
que c'est le traumatisme de la grippe à
chin N1 où on avait eu tellement peur et
qui s'est avéré être en fait une toute
petite grippe pas sévère est-ce que
voilà est-ce que les les médias ont
préféré entendre des personnes
rassurantes est-ce que je n'ai pas la la
voilà je n'ai pas la solution je pose un
certain nombre de questions à la fin du
livre he dans l'analyse vraiment de
retour d'expérience oui mais il y a
plein de fois où vous dites moi j'ai
j'ai envoyé des messages à Emmanuel
Macron à Édouard Philippe ils m'ont pas
répondu est-ce que quand même il y a une
responsabilité répondent ils me
répondent quand je suis ministre il est
clair que les réponses sont immédiates
tout le temps et donc il faut pas dire
qu'il ne répondent pas ils répondent et
d'ailleurs nous faisons moi je veux pas
laisser croire au français que nous
n'avons pas préparé nous avons préparer
d'ailleurs c'est c'est quelque chose qui
me choque énormément depuis 4 ans c'est
aussi la raison pour laquelle je publie
ce livre c'est qu'il y a l'idée que
personne n'était préparé or en réalité
la préparation au pandémie c'est un
travail permanent de l'Organisation
mondiale de la santé des ministères il y
a des traités internationaux il y a des
groupes de travail il y a des
recommandations nous faisons des
exercices de crise tous les mois en fait
tout le monde se prépare à une pandémie
aux États-Unis il y a vraiment des
classements internationaux des pays sur
leur préparation au pandémie la France
est dans les cinq premiers les
États-Unis sont le numéro 1 et pourtant
rien ne fonctionne c'est ça le retour
d'expérience qu'on devrait avoir
pourquoi alors qu'on est tous préparés
qu'on travail tous ensemble qu'on fait
des recommandations pourquoi rien ne
fonctionne au lieu et au lieu de ça
j'entends dire nous n'étions pas
préparés non c'est une mauvaise analyse
il faut comprendre pourquoi les
préparations ne fonctionnent pas ils
vous ont fait un retour Emmanuel Macron
Édouard Philippe sur Liv pas encore je
je l'URIS évidemment donné avant de le
publier voilà avec une dédicace bien sûr
on peut savoir laquelle ou pas on saura
pas alors on l'a dit vous exprimez
évidemment votre regret d'être allé en
campagne à la mairie de Paris est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui la politique c'est fini
pour vous aujourd'hui j'ai envie de
reprendre une activité où je suis utile
il est clair que mon engagement pour la
santé publique mon engagement politique
même il y a beaucoup de politiques dans
ce les vous parlez uniquement du
coronavirus mais il y a beaucoup de
réflexion politiqu euh parce que y en a
beaucoup oup c'est que le temps presse
on aurait envie non mais notamment sur
il y a beaucoup de choses qui qui qui
sont passionnantes notamment sur la
question des soignants vous dites c'est
un métier pas comme les autres c'est pas
uniquement une question de
revalorisation c'est pas uniquement une
question matérielle il faut aussi tenir
compte de la souffrance psychique et
psychologique des soignant ça c'est
aussi un appel au gouvernement S c'est
pas un appel non non c'est une réflexion
vraiment j'ai voulu utiliser ce que j'ai
vécu au ministère et comme soignante
pour attirer l'attention euh de ceux qui
liront le livre sur le fait que tout
n'est pas une question d'argent et que
souvent en politique on résume les
politiques publiqu à combien on met
d'argent et en réalité beaucoup de
politiques publiques sont beaucoup plus
complexes et que les transformations
elles nécessitent aussi euh autre chose
que simplement des finances
effectivement il y a il y a beaucoup de
de sujets on est en pleine loi
bioéthique aussi hein vous vous racontez
tout ça juste sur la politique parce que
on on vous m'avez pas répondu non quand
je vous demande est-ce que la politique
c'est finie vous avez dit non il y 5 ans
aux européennes est-ce que là vous avez
envie d'y aller je je vraiment la
question ne se pose pas aujourd'hui ce
qui compte pour moi déjà c'est que on
est un retour d'expérience collective
sur cette crise ce livre pour moi est
une contribution au débat public c'est
un décryptage j'espère qu'il sera utile
et après je verrai là où je peux être
utile donc c'est pas non merci agès
Buzin merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité ce livre est pas ce Nant il
raconte évidemment cette crise covid de
l'intérieur ces journal avec ce ce ce
sous-titre Agnès tu as fait peur au
président parce qu'on en a pas parlé
mais ça c'est un sms d'Alexis CER c'est
c'est c'est une conversation ou qui vous
dit que vous vous avez un peu inquiété
Emmanuel Macron c'est à lire évidemment
c'est aux éditions flamarion merci
beaucoup merci agè Buzin d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin on passe au club
de territoire